just in case for the one percent who
don't know who you are
what your relationships are and oh my
gosh where should i even begin
just just if you had to explain to
someone at the bar
what your channel is about oh man you're
talking to a normie yeah i
actually like just hang out with mostly
normies outside of like just youtube and
whenever like someone who doesn't know
who i am like when they ask oh what do
you do i literally just say i work from
home
it's just the easiest thing to say
because the moment that i say that like
i'm a youtuber maybe you guys have like
had this but
i just feel like that just opened so
many doors but that means nothing in
2020 because everyone's working at home
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm just like oh i do
like marketing
it's just i i try to pick it up
that's basically how i started
explaining my job to my parents the
first time
i started doing it yeah yeah yeah i i i
have to tell my i have to tell my
grandma that i'm a comedian
it's just like oh i know those yeah but
no like and then i do have like those
moments where i
say that i'm a youtuber and then i just
go into the details what's your youtube
channel about
my youtube channel honestly like people
have just said she's not an anime
channel anymore or she's still in
animation honestly
though yeah
i'm just more of like just an otaku
channel i'm just
someone that lives in japan that just
shares their life and what they like to
do here
but i don't know it's weird because i
still don't really know
what i am because i used to call myself
just anime youtube
but then like i'm too jvlogged to be
anime but then i'm too anime to be a
vlog
so i just thought oh otaku channel
that's probably the easiest thing he
needs labels i don't really
yeah yeah i'm just starkey dearest i
thought connor's in the same realm
though right it's like yeah pretty much
youtube and i'm like i don't i
mean we both do stuff around japan like
and it's just like i don't know i feel
like
as an anime fan especially when like as
an anime fan i do
all these other things beca in in japan
because when you like anime it just puts
japan in front of you
and then it just puts like all of these
other things so that's why i'm okay with
talking about like
i don't know just like japanese products
or like you know just
when i blew up i talked about vocaloid
because i always just thought even
though it's not an anime it's just
something every anime fan knew
it just somehow made its way it's kind
of just like the weeb culture
yeah yeah yeah essentially i feel like
you don't need to know anything about
anime to watch my content but i feel
like you get a lot more out of it if you
are
yeah yeah and that kind of humor i guess
yeah yeah
i feel there's a lot more like quote
unquote and youtubers who are kind of
going in that direction too like
i i'd say like i'm going in that
direction i think that's where most
anime youtube is going
because anime content is just not
performing well because well not not
performing as well
yeah as it was yeah like you can't make
like a 30 minutes i think this season's
been really good for anime content but
for the past year it was pretty rough
right like 2020 2019 was really rough
for anime
it's funny because i feel like it's
really just the hype that attack on
titan
has brought that people that's just
reminded people oh yeah anime exists
guys
anime actually exists yeah yeah and
that's that kind of trickles down
to everything else yeah something else
but like you can't make like you know a
30 minute analysis video on some
seasonal show that's not the biggest one
now and guess what i know
we watched them too much in the first
place i just kind of watched stuff and
that's why i like
because you went to like anime
conventions yeah i went to anime but
like you know
i i mean i was just a pleb like i just
watched [ __ ] but i don't actually like
think that deeply
which is weird because like in the
beginning of my youtube i used to do a
lot more analytical stuff
and one of them i think is like your
favorite series that i dropped yeah a
long time ago
everything you didn't know about right
yeah yeah that one was pretty fun that's
when i did like some detective work
going into an anime of like
what every reference meant my favorite
one i got so over saturated on youtube
yeah you know what i
did eventually 107 things you need to
know about naruto
yeah no no it was more like 100 things
you didn't know about naruto but like 97
of them
really obvious i think it was like the
vocaloid videos that popped up
and like the folklore and i think give
me videos that popped up originally
there's literally just one ghibli video
and i remember like
there's so i don't know why the [ __ ]
that blew up but yeah i know
also vocaloid what's funny is that the
vocaloid video
the first one that went up i originally
was not going to post that
because i just thought uh now i'm just
going over like vocaloid songs who cares
but then
and then um the file almost crashed
like uh the the night that i was going
to upload that but then like
looking luckily enough there's like
autosave stuff
so i went through like all these [ __ ] if
i was like please tell me that you saved
it somewhere
and i just uploaded and then the next
morning like actually within that week
then it started to blow up and i
remember
um yeah we were still really early in
our friendship
uh and i think when i blew up i like
gotten a call with you
i wanted to like vomit at like the
numbers that were growing because i
didn't know how to handle
because you were getting like i think
it's like 100k a week or something
something ridiculous